[Alkış]
e
herkese merhaba bugün sizlere yıllar
önce yanıma aldığım bir soru ve yine
yıllardır cevabını aradığın bir soruyla
yani
kahramanımızı Yok Sizce
t'nin Hala tutacağına inanak mı yoksa
helikopteri tutacağına inanarak muğalata
sarıldım Siz bu soruyu düşünürken Ben de
[Müzik]
çok güzel Anlatamam yeni insan
kaynakları Derneği'nin 5 yıldır kurucu
başkanlığını yürütüyorum Adana İŞKUR da
devlet memur olarak çalışıyorum
geçmişten Anladım insan kaynakları
Platformu kurucuları üstlenmekte
birlikte bu yolda kar yağ konuştuğundan
körlük Kariyer planlama uzmanlığı gibi
birçok alanda ilerlemiş bulunmaktayım
adını ilk kez düzenlenen insan
kaynakları zirvesinde düzenleme
kurumundan yine 10 yıldır zaten istihdam
fuarında
yönetiyorum film da aldık filmler devam
edelim hepimiz izlemişizdir
izlemeyenlere mutlaka tavsiye ederim mi
For Vandetta da bu maskenin altında bir
fikir var ve fikirlere Kurşun işlemez
ler ver zaman zaman hepimiz de mutlaka
düşünmüşümdür aklımıza gelen fikirler
olmuştur bunu mutlaka hayata geçiren
birileri tarafından ayıklanmış hızdır ya
da kendimiz hayata geçirdiğimizde
Bununla ilgili çok mutluluk duymuşuzdur
Bununla ilgili de benim de küçük bir
hikayem var ama tam da o hayata geçirmek
konusuyla ilgili çok sevdiğim nasıl
filmden İyilik yap iyilik bu filminde
öğretmen yüzyılın öğrencileri Dünya'yı
değiştirmek için bir fikir bulun ve bunu
hayata geçirildiği vermiş olduğu bir
ödev telefonu hikâyesinde başladı ödev
bu filmi mutlaka izlemenizi tavsiye
ederim ki benim de buna benzer bir
hikayem var tam da Bunlar renklendirmek
istiyorum bir gün uzun bir yolculuğa
sevgili bir Dostumla çıktık onunla
birlikte gittiğimiz yerde Aslında bugüne
kadar tüm çalışmalarımızın başladığı yer
olan ilki bu kaynakları camiasıyla toplu
olarak tanıştığım yıkama gelmiştik çok
büyük bir atmosfer vardı tanıdığım
dostlarım vardı tanımadığım dostlarım da
vardı ve bir noktada sevgili dostumdan o
yolun dönüşünde konuştuğumuz bir diyalog
var Kendisi bana ne düşünüyorsun
demiştim ben
ama biz orada konuşan hiç genç görmedik
Hatta dinlenen insanlar görmedik
demiştin Peki aklında bir şey var mı
demişti
kendisinin bana yıllardır söylediği şeyi
kendisine söyledim biz neden Adana'da
böyle bir yapılanma inşa etmiyoruz bugün
geldiğimiz noktadan 7 bine yakın insan
kaynakları profesyonel ile tanışma
Hikayemiz ve bununla birlikte 19010
Varan öğrenci yeni mezun insan
kaynakları alanında çalışmak isteyen
insanlarla tanışma Hikayemiz Tam da
bundan sonra Almış olduğumuz aksiyonla
başladı ve ben o günü her zaman
hatırlayarak anlatırım ve buradan
çıkaracağımız dersinde aksiyon almak
olduğunu söylerim Bunu kendimize koyalım
lazım olur
ve güzel söylemiş Mevlana kötü bir
döneme girdiğini ve her şey üstüne
geliyormuş gibi hissettiğinde bir dakika
bile dayanamayacak muşsun gibi
hissettiğinde sakın pes etme çünkü bu
işte orası gidişatın değişeceği yerdir
zamandır dar [ __ ] da buna benzer bir pes
etmeme hikâyesinden de size bahsetmek
isterim
bir öğrencimiz de çalışmıştık
mezuniyetine kadar süreçlerde beraberdik
Birgün karşıma heyecanla bir iş
görüşmesine anlatmaya geldi ben
reddedildiğini biliyordum o geldi büyük
bir heyecanla tüm hikayesini Herkesin
içinde anlatırken
sürecin nasıl ilerleyeceği bana sordu
Ben de ona Hadi kat biraz yürüyorum
dedim tam Tekrar konuşmaya başlayacaktı
ki
reddedildim
dediğimde sesi kesildi ağzını bıçak
açmıyordu yol boyunca yürüdük Nefes alış
şekli bile değişti arkadaşlar ve yolun
sonunda O hayal kırıklığını gördüğümde
ona Başka bir arkadaşımın gönderdiğin
mesajdan bahsettim gel hadi birlikte bir
hayal kuralım
yurtdışına bir yılan vermiş bir
arkadaşım var bu şekilde kısmetim
oradadır
buna başvurmayan edersin dedim Gözleri
Hala dolu Ne Kadar Büyük Hayaller
kurduğum Ben
bugün acımı yaşamak istiyorum eve gidip
sessiz izindeyim bunu yarın dışında
bilirmiyiz dedi
ben ona giderken sakın Pes Etme iyi bir
arada istedim bunu birçok insanın
söylüyorum Çünkü Pes Etme hikayeleri çok
fazla ben de olmakla birlikte hep
sonunda mutlu hikayeler dinlemiştir bir
o yine de arkasını dönüp gitti gece
12.00 buçuk yıl mesaj geldi Her gün ben
oynama başvurmak istiyorum
gitti geldi
görüşme olumlu geçti gitti geldi Ergin
bey ikinci görüşme deyim dedi gitti
geldi müdürü ile beni tanıştırmaya geldi
gitti daha gelmedi
Evet şu an Budapeşte adı Tam da o hayal
kırıklıklarını üzerine pes etmeme
hikayesiyle başladı hayatında bir gün
bana pes etmeme hikayelerini anlatmak
için de söz vererek gittim onun gibi
birçok hikaye var sıramız kısıtlı O
yüzden sadece şunu söylemek istiyorum ki
Pes etmeyin pes etmek güzel bir iki
aydır Bence bunu koyalım canımızı
bu açmadın
bu
hepiniz ama hakkını orada bir şeyler
gelmiştir
böyle düşünmüyoruz dur Ama bugün bir
arkadaşım Bununla ilgili tesadüfen de
bizim de söyledi ama ayak kokusundan mış
Bu
benim hikayem daha farklı bir yerde iki
kişi Çünkü
benim ortasındayız pandemi yeni bitmiş
bir arkadaşımla birlikte o pandomin o
gittiği dönemlerde herkesin de biraz
Tedirgin olduğu dönemlerde
çıktığımızda kimseyi göremedik ama
gittiğimiz ilk numaraları anlaştık suyun
içine girdik Ben Tatilin tadını
çıkartıyorum denize de yapmışım sırtüstü
yüzme ile çok Bilmem var yerine
Geçemiyorum halatın tam dibindeyim şey
yanımdan bir ses Biz insan kaynakları
yetiştirme programı ile ilgili projemizi
niye yapmadık
kafayı kaldırdım
ayağımın duymuyor bir kutu kısası Zaten
etrafa baktım etrafta insan yok Herhangi
akıllı diyorum ama diğer taraftan da
yapalım ya dedim Evet böyle bir projemiz
Vardı bizim askıya daldık pandemic
hiçbir şey yapamıyoruz düşünün ki o güne
kadar hep insanların bu ile beslenmiş
bir yapılanmanın içerisindeyiz ve
sosyallik denen şeyin zerresi yok online
ortamda yapacağız geldik yönetimimize
konuşuruz herkes karşı Çünkü hepimizin
örnekleri var ki eğitimlere gelen
arkadaşlarım beni çok iyi bir kamerayı
kapatıp arkadan başka şeyler mutlaka
yapıyoruz dur ne kadar ki olmaz
en yaratıcı bir kenara bıraktık inanma
ile baskı ladık Evet biz buna inanıyoruz
ve yapacağız dedik tabi inanıyoruz
deyince arkadaşlarımız sağolsun bizi hiç
yalnız bırakmadılar Bayağı da
kalabalıktı kalabalık bir çevirelim bu
projeye başladık ikincisini yaptık Bugün
inanılmayan projeden mezun olan
arkadaşlarımızın temsad ama enerjisada
Tosyalı Holding de istemiyor de Turkcell
Global de Tuborg daha çalıştığını
düşündüğümüzde İlk o denize gitmişiz
diyorum İyi ki arkadaşım bana küçük bir
çıtlat mış bu konuyu diyorum İyi ki
projeye başlamışız diyorum Çünkü
yaratıcılık ve inanmak bence çok önemli
değerler anca onları da koyalım da be
Bu
sıra sonunda başlıyor çok da severim
Hatta hepimiz Joker karakterini daha çok
tutmuşuz dur O filmde ama ben size 3.
filmden bir kesit ve gireceğim tamam
nükleer bombanın patlayacağı bir anda
James hortumla Kahraman Batman karşı
karşıyadır Batman Uçağa binip helikopter
uçakla birlikte
bombayı götürecektir o sırada Cenk
ortalama birşey sorar
şehri kurtaran kahramanın kim olduğunu
herkesin bilmeye hakkı var en azından
bana kim olduğunu söyle o sırada tam
yapılan bu
geçmişinden bir parça ile herkes
Kahraman olabilirler
Serhat'ta yetim bir çocuğun omzuna ceket
koyup ona hala hayatım bitmediğini
gösteren sade ve güven veren bir hareket
yapabilen biri bile
bir akşam saat 11 civarında bir proje
başvurusu yapıyorduk yanında bir genç
kızımız telefonu çaldı
arayan babası bu böyle birlikteyim dedi
Tamam kızım dedi ve telefonu kapattı
Şimdi mercimek
baban
babasını tanımıyorum hala çalışmak
üzerinden geçen iki yıla rağmen ve
ona Babam beni nereden tanıyor diye
sorduğumda bana dönüp ben anlatıyorum
Hocam size çok güveniyor Ben de çok
güveniyorum dedi mi
ve hatta bambaşka yerlerde
bizimhikayelerimiz anlatıyor dedi öyle
kendi dedim nasıl
ben onu bıraktım eve geldim uykum kaçtı
ne yaptım da bu noktaya gelecek kadar
hikayemizin başkalarını anlatılacak
noktaya geldiğimizi
düşünüyordum sonra güven bence zaten çok
önemli bir olduk hala o süreci korumaya
devam etme kararı aldım
gelirken
sorumuz tekrar atılıyor istiyorum
abone ol
çok acı helikopter da ona güvenen birisi
vardı
aşağıda onu bugüne kadar sağlayan tek
insan güvendiği tek insan aşağıdaydı
Bu ne oğlum o an yaratıcı düşünmesi
gerekiyordu aklıma gelen ilk şey
helikopterin halasına sarılmak oldu
sen buna inandın
bu aksiyon alıp halata sarıldı sonra
yolun sonuna kadar pes etmeyerek
helikopteri tutmaya devam etti yolun
sonunda O ipi kopması ya da kopmaması
ile ilgili Bence bir düşüncesi yoktur
Evet
Ee helikopter tutmaya başladı Biz
hepimiz de şu an Benim anlattığım
hikayelerini dinledik
Ben de şimdi sizden borç olarak
sevdiklerinizi alıyorum
Allah hepimizin bir sevdiğini
yaşanmışlığını hikayesini helikoptere
koyuyorum
daha sonra diyorum ki hayatım bir ucunu
size uzatıyorum hepinize hepiniz
sorumlusu şu an
güvenen biri var
ve helikopter düşer
Sıkı tutun Çünkü çıkacak başka kimsesi
yok
verdikten sonra burada
Evet Tamda Benim beş yıl önce
arka sıralardan bir gün bu sahneye
çıkmak istiyorum dediğim hikayemi Ayla
Şaştım tek kişi sonrasında birçok
insanlar Onun bir hayaliyle
bağdaştırarak anlatmıştım gerçek
olmayabilir bir olmayabilir bu sahneye
çık ama ya bilirim ama hayalini kurmak
bile çok güzel demiştim Tam beş yıl
sonra ben çevresinde dediği gibi o gün
düşündüğüm şeyin gerçek olması defalarca
kelime mail attığım halde cevap
alamamıştım tam hayalimi unuttuğum bir
günde bir konuşmada bir arkadaşımın bana
bu sahnede konuşmaya ne dersin dediği
anda çekelim Ender zamanlar yaşamıştım
Çünkü ben Hayalini bile unutmuştum o gün
hayalin gerçekleştiği sahnedeyim tam
hikayenin bittiğini inandığımı düşündüm
O zamanlar daha yaklaşmadan daha birçok
şeyi anlatacak Bakkal biriktirmek var
derken
bu hikaye saniye çıkmakla yarım kalsada
ben gittim dinlediğiniz için hepinize
teşekkür ediyorum
saygılar Siz var bu